el costo de ponerle gasolina al coche
custom es directamente proporcional a la
cantidad de litros la cantidad de litros
de gasolina que le pones déjame escribir
esto aquí abajo con algunas letras vamos
a ponerle x a la cantidad de litros
comprados al número de litros y litros
comprados los que le ponemos al coche
comprados y vamos a ponerle ye yé al
costo al costo
de lo que gastamos en esa apuesta de
gasolina vale entonces nos dicen que el
costo es directamente proporcional a la
cantidad de litros comprados es decir
que podemos escribir hay como una cierta
constante multiplicada por equis eso es
que ya sea directamente proporcional a x
bueno vamos a seguir además nos dicen si
un litro de gasolina cuesta 1250 cuántos
litros puedes poner con 100 pesos bueno
pues vamos a ver qué información nos da
esto de aquí dice 1 litro de gasolina
cuesta 1250 es decir tenemos que si x es
igual a 1 si x es igual a 1 entonces es
igual a 12.5 12.5 entonces con esta
información podemos obtener el valor de
k como sigue
simplemente sustituimos obtenemos que
12.5 12.5 es igual a k por equis acá
por uno pero acá por uno es simplemente
cara entonces esto lo puedo tachar y
aquí nos queda que acá es igual a 12.5
acá es igual a 12.5 muy bien entonces
con este valor de cada ya podemos saber
el costo en términos de x nos quedaría
que ye yé es igual a 12.5 por equis y
ahora lo que nos preguntan es cuántos
litros puedes poner con 100 pesos es
decir nos están dando el valor de g y
con eso queremos determinar el valor de
x de los litros déjame hacer esta
operación por acá
voy a agarrar este color rosa entonces
sabemos que es igual a 100 y es igual a
100 y eso tiene que ser igual a 12.5 x
cómo le hacemos para obtener x pues
dividimos a ambos lados de la igualdad
entre 12.5 hacemos 100 entre 12.5 y
vamos a hacer esta operación a ver
cuánto nos queda nos quedaría que x x es
igual a vamos a hacer la división haber
12.5 12.5 es lo mismo que 12 más un
medio y 12 más un medio es lo mismo que
24 uno o sea 25 medios entonces si
hacemos 100 entre 12.5 eso es lo mismo
que hacer 100 por 2
por dos porque estamos dividiendo entre
25 medios y esto dividirlo entre 25 25
100 entre 25 es igual a 4 y 4 por 2 es
igual a 8 y de esta forma la cantidad de
litros que podemos poner con 100 pesos
es 8x es igual a 8 litros
muy bien